there's a mystery at Walter filtration
manufacturer multi-pro International
that needs to be solved and the Girl
Scouts of Southern Nevada Junior
detectives are on the job the simulation
is part of the CSI Junior detective
series The Girl Scouts teamed up with
multi-pure to host a monthly steam
series stem series rather giving the
young girls the chance to solve
Mysteries through science with one help
of an on-site scientist
for little girls who are dreaming and
they're watching shows and they're
reading Nancy Drew or some of those old
crime things I think for them to realize
they can actually be that person is
really great it doesn't matter about who
you are or what you do you can do
anything
now participants aren't an activity
patch and complete steps on the way to
their junior detective badge